[Musica]
questa canzone si chiamava fare con la zona
[Applausi]
[Musica]
Non lo so
e tanto
cura chiusa
[Musica]
è per il mondo tritato
e basta
da te
le notizie
[Musica]
10°
cammini con misericordia città
non si sa cosa
cos'altro
e
[Musica]
[Applausi]
per più
A volte
in arrivo
[Musica]
nessuno si ferma
dire luminoso e futuro
essi prendono
un tornado
sposarsi
[Musica]
gloria
h
digli di rotolare
[Musica]
sarà
vita
Guarda
Oh
e
chi vuole
no
Oh
Y
[Musica]
[Applausi]
Si può curare
qui
è stata presa cura
Y
[Musica]
[ride]
[Applausi]
grazie e assimila
che sarà dato con l'area che un po '
è la canzone
Ho iniziato una missione auto-psicanalizzata
scrive l'europa
la prossima volta colui che viveva in alto
memoria di cui nulla possiede l'idea
la mia idea personale che la visione e il
montepío con la sua prevalenza ma potere
per l'area e alte potenza diretta oper
giochi con un argomento importante
come la musica che costa energia
comunicativo di cui hanno ottenuto la finestra
la contea con la mia e l'etica
con quello che ho bolero
quella canzone si chiama perla di terranova
[Musica]
perché
inizia la notte
di montagne appuntite
la pelle
fine
Non so da dove venga
[Musica]
non è noto
Guarda
[Musica]
può essere
sorpresa
no
[Musica]
e
no
[Musica]
D
nerd
la ragazza
S
per me
[Musica]
h
per me
[Musica]
Marita
uno
e punto
[Musica]
Avanzare
in quinta
il consigliere
mi sono sentito
no no no
[Musica]
[Applausi]
Grazie